hey y'all time for the movie
retrospective this one kind of came out
of nowhere and this is how this happened
I got a message from one of our patrons
Jonna it's I think that's how you
pronounce her name jonah and scott
they've they've been our patrons for a
really long time and she messaged me and
she said oh I noticed that you guys have
been doing like a lot of kind of cult
classic 80s movies and stuff she's like
you should get around to doing the gate
she's like fun fact Scott who was you
know one of our patrons was an extra in
that movie okay she sent me a screenshot
with a little arrow pointing which which
I asked them I said is it okay if I put
it in the video and they said that it
was so he was only 16 at the time he
wishes one of the kids at the party you
know I mean which if you've seen the
movie you'll know to talk about but I
was just like so delighted and then that
ice and then I saw that it was a one of
the free movies on YouTube so I said
well why not I had another movie
scheduled for this week but I said we
can switch it out so we'll do the gate
for this week and because I had seen it
a bunch of times when I was a kid and I
really enjoyed it and Tom had never seen
it no I saw it sitting believably I saw
it sitting up on like the shelves at
like Blockbuster and other places where
you could rent videos I would see it all
the time actually it was that they had
it at the local corner store when in
Mississippi would go down to visit my
dad it was there forever because they
were written they were renting videos
and I never [ __ ] rented it and I in
the scene it I should have oh yeah I
mean you would think that that would be
like right up your alley although you
might have been maybe it was 87 so you
might have been slightly too old for it
no no I didn't know anything about it
okay I just saw the cover and I was like
that I don't think I like that when that
one looks cheap you know I mean I didn't
know you know didn't know anybody hit it
really just looking at that I was
looking at the back of it you know I
mean and I was all like who are these
people
you know I never heard about this movie
you know it wasn't like you know like a
like you know movie with Jeffrey Combs
or anything you know I mean so I just
didn't think it was to be any good so I
never I never rented it but watched it
and it was
real good real good you know kind of
kind of like something Spielberg would
it make made kind of like I thought at
the time it kind of had a similar tone
to poultrygeist
yeah it has a very poltergeisting vibe
yeah mixed with kinda like I don't know
gremlins or something yeah it's
definitely falls in that and I think
this is why a lot of you know 80s horror
kids remember it so fondly not only
because it's a really good movie but
also because it falls right in that
sweet spot where it's like a horror
movie but kids can still watch it yeah
but it kids can watch it but it's not
like lame I remember thinking it was
gonna be like really low budget like a
really super low b-movie you know that's
what I thought it would be like but I
saw it had great special effects it was
a good movie for John stop motion in
this is it still yeah standing yeah all
practical effects yeah but I didn't know
at the time so I never I never rented it
yeah yes because it wasn't a Hollywood
movie
Hollywood didn't didn't oh yeah it's
like it's a Canadian American
co-production right so it didn't get any
promotion in the United States although
it actually in the US when it came out
it was second I think and it made quite
a bit of money because this only cost um
two and a half million to make amazingly
which was pretty cheap even for 87 when
it came out but it's just it's just such
a great [ __ ] and also this was
Stephen Dorff first movie he was just a
little kid in this I don't know how old
he was when he was in this maybe like 11
or 12 or something which my could we
couldn't figure out how old he was
obviously he went on and to be in blade
he was in Cecil Peter Benton he was in
like all these other kind of [ __ ]
movies and so this was his first one and
all the acting in this is actually
really good I was watching a couple
other because um I think Brandon 10 old
did a review of this because on his
Canucks ploy tation cuz he's Canadian so
he'd always does every year he does a
Canadian film festival like one month
and I also saw it on red letter media x'
review they did one on
well and they were talking about one of
the coolest things about this movie
other than it falling into that really
like I don't want to say kid-friendly
horror even though that's kind of what
it is like you said it's kind like
gremlins are poltergeist or you know
Monster Squad or something like that
this is probably scarier than Monster
Squad yeah I was gonna say you know
we're we're calling it kid-friendly not
really wouldn't be considered
kid-friendly by today's standards it's I
mean it's people 13 is pg-13 but it's
quite hardcore actually it's pretty gory
for a kid's movie and you know there's a
lot of strong language that you could
have in it and it was very different
because an American version of some [ __ ]
like this would be like Goonies or you
know something like gremlins and the
kids don't really go in the American
versions the kids don't really go up
against any kind of serious threat or
any kind of serious challenge really it
and and they get out of [ __ ] quite
easily in this one man the kids [ __ ]
suffered man fighting demons and [ __ ]
yeah it's gonna happen it's almost
Lovecraftian yeah I I guess it didn't
occur to me at the time but then when I
was thinking about it I'm like you know
that basically the whole gist of the
plot is that you know Stephen Dorff
plays a kid named Glenn and he has his
neighbor whose name is Terry I think
it's his same age or a little bit older
like Terry is like a nerdy heavy-metal
kid and Glen has an older sister who was
15 or almost 16 the parents their
parents go out of town for the weekend
or whatever and you know the sister
Alexandra or al is she's called insists
that she is old enough to not need a
babysitter you know she can look after
Glen she can look after the kid and
everything like that so the parents
decide to let them stay all weekend by
themselves and it turns out that they
sort of accidentally summoned some
demons from a hole in the backyard where
a rotten tree was pulled out with I
guess with the help of that's the thing
it's like there's they find a geode and
they crack it open
and I think what ends up happening they
don't do it on purpose but it's like the
the kid next door Terry he has this this
album this is like the Asians like the
satanic heavy metal and stuff like that
so it's kind of this cool album design
and this band you know I guess I can't
remember what they were called but it
was like some kind of funny name it
start with an S but it has like the
album has this booklet in it called the
dark book which is kind of like an
equivalent of the Necronomicon and it
says how to summon demons and Terry's
like oh you know the band is they're
European and my dad bought brought me
this back from Europe and stuff is like
this band only made one album and they
all died in a plane crash just like
Lynyrd Skynyrd I guess or whatever and
uh so they said like spinal tap but yeah
so so there was that whole thing so that
so they end up like a whole bunch of
stuff happens that like accidentally
summons the demons from this hole in
their backyard like I think like Glenn
like it's a splinter in his finger and
it gets blood in there you know they did
they played the record and let me stop
you right here all right to the younger
audience this might sound really [ __ ]
far-out like really outlandish but you
have to understand that during this era
there was no social media if you were
young social media was actually this
music and sometimes like circus magazine
which was about damn rock music yeah I
remember that and you know depending on
you know also what ethnic group you were
you know rap was kind of a similar scene
you know if you were black you're you
were up with the [ __ ] rap bands and
all the trauma that was going on between
them and you knew other base
personalities and they had [ __ ]
magazines dedicated to it kind of like
martial arts and wrestling well in the
[ __ ] heavy metal scene at this during
this time you would sit there in your
room as a kid and listen to a whole
[ __ ] album every song back-to-back
and you sit there and look at that damn
album cover listening to it because
chances are you know you could you know
she had MTV you know when you were
little when you were older and [ __ ] but
you probably couldn't be jamming out too
much with MTV or MTV
wouldn't be playing your black metal
albums yeah yeah and I mean so you had
to just look at the damn album and
[ __ ] listen to the damn music and
trying to you know go through that go
through all the lyrics well the guys
that had these bands knew you were doing
that so they would put all kinds of
outlandish [ __ ] in the [ __ ] car and in
the lyrics and all these [ __ ] secret
messages and hidden messages then it got
to the point to where you as a [ __ ]
heavy metal kid went out of your way to
go look for these [ __ ] messages and
you probably were just inventing
messages well probably you know you're
reading into [ __ ] if you play stuff
backwards like you you know it's like
audio pareidolia where it sounds like
something so when you're seeing this
movie and you're seeing this kid do this
get into this music in this album cover
him because he looked at the looked at
the lyrics too long and did this and
that and it actually brought demons out
you're like well yeah of course I've
been trying that shit's finally [ __ ]
work that's that's that's what you're
talking about here it was just a
different time yeah well and I think -
one of the other cool one of the other
cool things about this movie I really
liked that they nailed I mean that was
kind of like it wasn't the kids were not
annoying in it um the kids were like
realistic like it I feel like they
talked realistically they give realistic
[ __ ] it was because it was Canadian had
it yeah American it would have been
[ __ ] up
the only good American one really they
had kids and if he has to be like Lost
Boys
Lost Boys was not remember had they had
a couple of yeah although yeah there
they were like older but they were a
little bit older but they were it was
kind of like watching lost voice they
were kids that were watchable yeah yeah
no I mean even though they were younger
like you said it yes oh I like I like
that they did that they didn't make them
and like you said they were actually in
danger I mean some messed up stuff
happens in this movie and I've heard
that people that saw this when they were
kids back in 1987 like some of the [ __ ]
in there like stuck with them like
forever
like what like one of the particular
things with where Glenn Stephen Dorff
scare achter when I guess the demon I
guess I didn't get this
first time I watched it but we're
rewatching it that it seemed like why
didn't the demon take him or kill him I
think it's because the demon thought
that he had summoned him on purpose yeah
so he was like the master of it he had
command of it maybe and yeah because
like when I in his hand he reached down
grabbed him put me to I grow out of his
hand Shh yeah and he looked like that it
was like I was like an eyeball and he
may have some way asked for that and it
gave it to him I don't know that's what
I'm saying and well another cool thing
too is that it there's a lot of stuff
that's like subtle um you know like
there's stuff that's like the symbols
that are drawn on the wall like the
stuff that's in the dark book like
inside the album you really kind of have
to look at the artwork in there and
stuff like that to kind of explain like
what is happening like not like how
everything ties together yeah the little
people cut carving the guy up it pretty
foreshadow - a bunch of stuff that had
it really did yeah there's these little
demons to come out of the ground at
certain times in their little white
[ __ ] people and they look great I
still can't believe how [ __ ] awesome
those effects are they're probably about
ten inches tall about the size of a GI
Joe doll and they're swarming on guys
you know swarming on these kids and
trying to cut them up and do weird [ __ ]
I don't know how they did its its
practical effect it it didn't look like
stop-motion than me somebody's
stop-motion and some of it is forced
perspective forced perspective kind of
like in that cat's eye movie with the
little goblin that came out of yeah and
it looks good like that that's like
really a simple [ __ ] special effect
to do it's like really does it done diva
cost that much [ __ ] they even did it in
Lord of the Rings like with the hobbits
and stuff to make them look smaller and
particularly the one scene where Terry
falls into the hole like into the hole
in the backyard and all the little
demons are like down there and they're
like grabbing his leg and stuff like
that that looks looks real no that looks
like little bitty demons or like grab it
if it trying to pull them back in it
doesn't look like a fake leg it doesn't
look like fake little demons or anything
like that no the guy right it just it
looks really fantastic and the one kind
of showstopper I think because the demon
themselves the design of them is like
really really good it's like really
really creepy so when they do forced
perspective like I said it's it's dudes
in costumes and like puppets and things
like that but and then some of its
stop-motion but the one scene where I
guess earlier in the movie Terry tells
this like what is supposedly an urban
legend that oh hey Glen when they were
working on your house like a work man
died and they like walled him up inside
the wall like they were trying to like
freak each other out and stuff yeah
which is yes so like later on in the
movie I guess the demons kind of like
pull stuff out of your head like to
scare you I'm assuming and so that so a
workman like falls out he's like a
zombie and [ __ ] and then there's one
point where he just like like falls
forward like you know without you know
just falls forward like that and then
when he hits the floor he turns into
like all these demons and apparently
that was done in camera and I cannot
figure out how they [ __ ] did it it's
not CGI
yeah it looks really good looking back
on on it because you see in in 87 I had
not heard of this movie yeah I just saw
it at the video rental place I kind of
think that maybe the Hollywood and the
theater gangsters may have been slightly
threatened by this movie so it probably
had a very limited release and didn't
have any promotion that I know of did if
it had a promotional campaign I didn't
hear about it it did I remember when it
came out yeah okay I didn't it must have
not been very far-reaching maybe had to
do what what um what region you were in
and I don't know I have any friends
talking about it yeah nothing about it
um you know until recently I just but I
remember that poster and the you know I
mean the cover of the box yeah with the
dam face coming out of the hole in the
ground with the claws yeah I remember
that but I never rented it didn't think
it's gonna be any good it's interesting
because like I said it did get to like
the second second place like at the box
office
yeah but I didn't know it only yeah
it'll it only costs two and a half
million to make and I believe it made
fourteen million in the theater and then
it started to like once it went to video
it started getting like a bigger you
know video and cable it started getting
a much bigger like audience and like
became a cult classic nowadays you can
go online and see
number two at the box office back in 87
you could you'd have to get some kind of
Hollywood magazine yeah a variety or it
would never be happy yeah and it would
never be matching watch Entertainment
Tonight yeah but they have that really
be mentioned on mainstream television
you might have to watch a special
program but you know when you're a
teenage guy you don't give a [ __ ] about
that man
yeah I was chasing girls just never I
never heard of it
never heard anything about it I just saw
it later a couple years later up there
at VHS rental yeah and you know man I
don't know I'm not the guy to rented it
or seen it in you know seen it in a
theater it was good well yeah like I
said it's it's kind of one of those cool
movies and um you know it it might be
just because I'm older and I saw it when
I was you know a teenager but I still
think it holds up and from what I've
read I like you know cuz I was watching
a bunch of other reviews of it and some
people were commenting because on red
lighter media the one guy was saying
he's like I wonder how how it holds up
he's like you know because I love it but
that's because you know I'm in my 40s
and I saw it when I was a kid and he's
like I wonder if it would hold up for
people in their 20s or people you know
in their 20s and 30s and their children
like if it would still be good to them
and a bunch of people came on and
commented they're like hey I'm 20 and I
loved this movie I just saw it you know
and some people were saying that this
was one of the first ones that they
showed their kids like when they're
trying to get their kids into horror you
know this one gremlins Monster Squad the
lady in white which actually was one of
my favorites from that time period
because there was like a really lot of
really good you know ostensibly kids
movies but that had like a lot of horror
elements to them and like I said this
one other than like the [ __ ] demons
they essentially summon demons you know
there's and all that kind of horrible
[ __ ] there's also one scene where Glen
an owl
you know the brother and sister they go
outside like in the middle of all the
chaos and they think that their parents
have come home early because their
parents are like walking up the driveway
and then the dad like picks up Glen by
the next thing like you babe
then when like sticks his fingers
through his dad's [ __ ] chick comes
out many Poles his dad's yeah it's like
I was [ __ ] gorgeous it like a [ __ ]
kids movie which I just thought was like
really really funny but as I said I
think that's kind of why a lot of people
have you know nostalgia for a lot of
these 80s movies is because even though
it was a kids movie there was [ __ ] in it
that when you were a kid you're like oh
man I probably should be watching this
you kind of think it was like you know
it was scary but that's kind of what
kids like that so you know what I mean
it was just kind of the same with
poltergeist with like the kid with like
the guy like going to the bathroom and
tearing his face off one like the the
chicken with all the maggots on it and
stuff like that where it's just had
these couple scenes where you're like
wow that's pretty [ __ ] up for like a
pg-13 one of the thing I noticed that I
liked about it was that they got the
fashion route right a lot of times in a
late eighties movie like an 87 they'd
have the people dressed up but they were
dressed up in clothes that you wouldn't
see on the street maybe seven they were
more like costumes or something that
some fashion designer you know like
product placement you know I mean people
didn't win dress like you actually
dressed but in this movie they did yeah
the girls especially the wind had their
hair cramped and the [ __ ] the one
girl that had the bangs like sticking up
my bangs it looked crazy but you know
what it was long and not hers like the
girl in the movies was short and she had
like the bangs like that but I knew a
girl that had been 87 out in 87 I was in
the down river area down river of
Detroit Michigan and this is a Canadian
movie and that's how they all looked
yeah in the Michigan area - that the
fashion was the same in 87
those damn colorful flowered shirts the
weird [ __ ] neat that the neon colors
uh-huh yeah you know two-tone -
different - and three different kinds of
neon Laird saw there saw like the one
sock you have the other sock with three
different colors Irish shoes all them
like the little white heads yep I
remember that kind of [ __ ] so yep and
then the [ __ ] the boys wearing
flannel and [ __ ] yeah yep but yeah they
did a really good job it's like you know
what I mean it's this really does see
like it was written by someone who you
know knew a lot about kids because it
wasn't like talking down to kids yeah
and you know like I said the kids were
not annoying they actually had to like
you know man up and you know get the get
dad's shotgun get all this hook and [ __ ]
like get rid of all this look yeah they
actually had to fight right and it's
like it was really really awesome and I
liked to the way I liked the
relationship between the brother and the
sister and how that was kind of like the
heart of the story but they didn't like
smack you over the head with it you know
what I mean like the whole point of him
having to like for him to defeat the
demon he had to use like the rocket it
was like a symbolic of his relationship
with his sister because he'd given it to
her for a birthday and she was growing
up and he didn't want her to grow up
because they had hung out and now she
was getting too old and wanted to be
like dude go do girly [ __ ] at the mall
and he was kind of bummed out about it
so that whole kind of dynamic played
into it but they didn't oversell that it
was just very very subtle like you you
know what I mean and I really liked that
they didn't just smack you on the head
was like how [ __ ] heartwarming the
[ __ ] was it was just it was there but it
wasn't like made a big deal out of your
basically dealing with a movie that is
it's a Canadian equivalent of a
Spielberg flick yeah I would say a
little bit more of a harder edge to it
it can hold its own against a Spielberg
flick at that time especially when you
consider how cheap it cost to make it I
still I still can't believe that it was
only two and half million definitely
punching away above its way especially
considering how [ __ ] awesome that
stop-motion looks how awesome the little
demons look even the really big demon
like at the end that has like the arm
tubes essentially like a much larger
version of the little ones except he has
like more arms and more tentacles and
more eyes and stuff even that looks
[ __ ] great and the score is kind of
like something out of us field work
flick it has that tone it has that yeah
it's like a suburban changed when kids
like accidentally like through really no
fault of their own you know get in this
horribly Lovecraftian
world-ending situation and have to like
you know use their Wiles to get out of
it like they can't escape from it and
they have to like kind of pull together
and figure out what to do about why
didn't me a lot of poltergeist kind of
yeah it is very much like that like
totally it is very much like that and
even like the house even though this was
shot in Canada you know the house the
neighborhood the whole like middle-class
kind of suburban family that whole
dynamic is the same so I it's funny
because and Brandon makes a lot of jokes
about this too because he's Canadian and
he's always like a lot of the Canadian
movies at the time they didn't really
want you to know that they were Canadian
I guess because they thought if it was
American it was like a much wider
audience
so they'd always kind of try to do [ __ ]
like put little American flags like I'm
lucky they didn't black Christmas they
put the little American flag on the cops
desk and and [ __ ] like that even though
you every now and then this one you
probably wouldn't know it was Canadian
every now and then like somebody says a
boot or something and it's like just
very sudden you're like oh I got that it
could almost be Michigan though yeah you
wouldn't really know like if you weren't
paying attention yeah but um yeah
Michiganders have a slight Canadian
accent a little bit yeah I think yeah
I've heard them talk so it's like I kind
of know where they're coming from but
yeah so this one definitely I think if
you have kids that are you know 9 10
something like that and you want to get
them into horror and are looking for
some movies to kind of ease them into it
that are scary but not too scary yeah um
this is actually a really good one
because there's some gore in it there's
some you know there's some bad language
with you know the two of the sisters
friends like tell the two points to stop
fagging off to which he replies he says
something like suck on my nose till my
head caves in or something I was like ok
but yeah so there's you know there's a
bad language and there's some kind of
like language they probably wouldn't use
anymore and there but you know there's
some gore and stuff the movie of its
time but it's got like a really good
message to it and
if you you know if you have a kid that's
like super into or wants to get into
horror and you know and looking for
something that's scary but not too scary
this is actually a really good one like
I said I would also recommend the lady
in white if you're it really into like
more like ghost story type stuff like
not so much gory stuff like mystery
ghost stories we'll have to review that
too because that's a really good one and
I really liked that when I was growing
up as well but yeah so definitely check
this one out if you haven't seen it it's
free on to be it's free on YouTube you
can see it lots of different places and
I definitely recommend it it's like it's
even way better than I remembered
because I hadn't seen it for many years
and I had kind of it was on the list but
I decided to pull it up just because
Jonah and Scott said that they wanted to
see it and said that Scott had been in
it so that's why I'm gonna put the
picture in there too with the little
arrow but yeah so I definitely check it
out